year after year a ton of incredible
films are released only to end up going
largely unnoticed and 2018 is no
different
but don't worry about missing out on all
the future classics slipping under the
radar
we've got the scoop on the very best
writer director chloe jowes the writer
breaks the barriers of what a true story
film can be
real-life south dakota rodeo writer
brady jandro leads as a faintly
fictionalized version of himself and
recounts the horror of the moment a
horse trampled him and the hardships he
faced afterwards
though shaken and stripped of the very
thing that gave him purpose brady
refuses to succumb to sorrow and
journeys across the badlands to find a
new identity
jandro's performance comes across
nuanced and naturalistic
gorgeously complemented by shots of the
south dakota sky
on the whole the film's ability to
deliver its dizzying narrative in a
beautiful package makes it critically
acclaimed but unfortunately under seen
in academy award-winning director
sebastian lelio's disobedience
wanting what you can't have isn't just a
simple taboo
disobedience stars rachel weiss as ramit
a non-practicing orthodox jewish woman
who returns to her buttoned-up london
community decades after her teenage
romance with a female school friend was
found out
rachel mcadams plays este the childhood
friend who still holds the passion for
run eat in her adulthood that she did in
her youth
once reunited the two fall into their
feelings once more
a dynamic made more complicated when
esty's husband
doveed gets involved balancing risky
dramatic material with poignant
rumination on centuries-long values
lelio creates a film that swirls with
strife as intensely as it stupefies with
its eventual truths
so everything was alright when i left
no i was ill
adapted from jim shepard's psychological
fiction novel project x
and then i go chronicles middle schooler
edwin's mounting stress as it snowballs
into insomnia and anxiety
edwin's world changes after his best
friend flake suffers a particularly
humiliating encounter with a bully and
suggests that he and edwin
silence their tormentors what unravels
after flake's idea is an intimate look
into the peaks of violence and pain
edwin rides through and how the two boys
suppressed fury fuels their terrifying
life or death plan to finally be
accepted
ethan hawk gives the performance of a
lifetime in first reformed the
mesmerizing loss of faith drama thriller
from writer director paul schrader
hawk plays reverend ernst toller a
middle-aged pastor who works at a
centuries-old dutch reform church that
draws in more tourists than it does
parishioners
grappling with his own grief and
dependence issues toller faces a
harrowing new
challenge when he meets pregnant
parishioner mary and her suicidal
husband michael
michael's radical beliefs compound
toller's spiritual crisis which leads to
his final
violent trial in an ending that will
leave you with plenty to think about
this isn't your mama's movie about
parenthood from director jason reitman
and writer diablo cody
tully stars charlize theron as marlo a
struggling mother of two who's pregnant
with her third child
at marlow's baby shower for her daughter
her wealthy brother craig offers to gift
her a night nanny
a young woman named tully though
reluctant at first marlo later agrees to
craig's proposition and she
her husband drew and tully embark on a
mind-bending journey that marries humor
with surprising sincerity
led by up and comer elsie fisher 8th
grade follows 13 year old kayla day as
she completes her final week of middle
school
kayla is awkward but well-meaning she
creates motivational youtube videos and
encourages others to carry themselves
with confidence that she doesn't seem to
have herself
she's every young teenage girl and bo
burnham's writing and direction
perfectly captures that in a sweet
heartwarming true to life movie
one more week of eighth grade right yeah
that's crazy yeah huh i can't believe
you're going to be in high school
from academy award-nominated director
and co-writer deborah granick leave no
trace begins just before the boiling
point
war veteran will and his 13 year old
daughter tom have been living in an
isolated section of a public park
when the survivalist duo make one small
misstep social services come calling
taking them in for extensive evaluations
and setting them up with everything they
need to live a normal life
though confused as to why anyone would
have previously considered her and her
father homeless
tom tries her hardest to adapt to her
new environment and embrace her
surroundings
her father however grows increasingly
rigid as both father and daughter try to
understand each other and their place in
the world i think it might be easier
on us if we try to adapt
wearing their clothes were in their
house were
15 years after the death of children's
television pioneer fred rogers
director morgan neville invites
audiences to celebrate the life of the
benevolent host of mr rogers
neighborhood
and honor the good heartedness and
empathy he taught more than just a
single subject documentary
won't you be my neighbor examines rogers
for who he was
outside the pbs series and beneath his
cozy cardigans
it reminds viewers that rogers was far
more amazing than anyone knew
the kind of compassionate creative that
the world could use many more of
anyone who doubted nick offerman's
ability to play characters other than
the mustachioed ron swanson on parks and
recreation needs to watch
hearts beat loud offerman shines as
brooklyn-based widower and musician
frank in the brett haley directed drama
that brings together the magic of music
and the intricacies of a father-daughter
relationship
when frank and his daughter sam finds
success after frank uploads one of their
songs to spotify their lives
shift in a new direction rather than
explore what happens to a parent and a
child who hit the road like real rock
and rollers
hearts beat loud pulls the story inward
documenting frank's fears of his
daughter leaving new york
sam's blossoming feelings for her
girlfriend rose and the pair's dual
acceptance that life may be scary but
that's what makes it beautiful
everyone who took a high school level
psychology class will know that one of
the most popular debates in the field is
that of nature versus nurture
whether we are the way we are because of
our genetics or because of our
upbringing
three identical strangers an equally
harrowing and heartwarming documentary
by tim wardle
sticks that question under a microscope
as it centers on bobby
eddie and david identical triplets who
are separated at birth
each adopted by different families of
different socioeconomic classes
the trio discover one another by chance
in 1980
19 years after their birth bobby and
eddie found out they were twins
after bobby was mistaken for eddie on
their college campus
and david learned he was the third
brother following press coverage of
bobby and eddie's reunion
but the joy-filled homecomings quickly
turned dark as the triplets search for
answers behind their adoptions which
lead them to shocking
life-altering secrets they were likely
never meant to uncover
based on emily m danforth's 2012 novel
of the same name
the miseducation of cameron post centers
on chloe grace moretz cameron post who
is outed as a lesbian when she's caught
kissing her female best friend
soon after cameron's conservative aunt
orders her to undergo conversion therapy
at a center called god's promise
there cameron forms friendships with a
handful of other teams who like her put
up a fight against being re-educated
it's a stirring coming-of-age movie
that's absolutely worth seeing
rafael casal and david diggs proved to
be triple threat talents in blind
spotting the comedy drama the pair wrote
produced and starred in under the
direction of first time feature
filmmaker carlos lopez estrada
diggs leads as colin a felon who's so
close to the end of his year-long
probation he can practically taste it
cassal plays his best friend miles a
troublemaker who offers
no support to colin and helping him make
it through the fateful final 72 hours of
his sentencing
where colin longs for a new beginning
miles actively seeks out danger in the
rapidly gentrifying streets of oakland
california
the pair's lives splinter when colin
witnesses a white cop kill a black man
and miles is fixation on violence and
his increasingly trigger happy mentality
threatens to have devastating
consequences
those who missed out on seeing blind
spotting in its original release should
remedy that misstep asap
and see why critics are calling this
provocative timely fully
underappreciated movie one of the most
unique films of 2018.
he went to jail on a fire technicality
did i yes
how are we supposed to know the hipsters
are so flammable
regina hall leads support the girls as
lisa the general manager of double
whammies a hooters-esque restaurant
lisa and her co-workers are trying to
make it as well as they can in the world
of customer service until they find
themselves stuck in a particularly
heinous day
lisa tries to hold it together but every
hour seems to bring even more problems
the real world bites the girls learn but
they bite back
support the girls as rock solid and
rollicking able to handle heavy themes
while still remaining buoyant
writer director crystal moselle takes
viewers to the concrete jungle to the
inner workings of a young woman's mind
into the half pipes tramps and grinding
rails of new york's many skate parks in
the down to earth drama skate kitchen
the film is an r rated exercise in just
how good movies can be when they're
simplistic and realistic
the movie follows introverted teenager
camille who joins the all girl
skateboarding group skate kitchen
camille's world cracks open wide
thereafter she leaves home
begins falling for her new roommate's
ex-boyfriend foster's confidence and
fights massage ginny
most importantly she learns how great
life can be with a pack of like-minded
ladies
at your side in the mystery thriller
searching jon cho
stars as david kim the father of 16 year
old margot who goes missing without a
trace after visiting a friend's house
for a group study session
david began searching for answers in
margot's laptop retracing the steps she
took online in hopes of bringing her
home before it's too late
what follows is a heart-stopping
jaw-dropping journey to uncover the
truth behind his daughter's
disappearance which is darker and more
complex than david could have ever
imagined
with its unique approach well sustained
suspense tight pacing and a final twist
you'll never see coming
searching is one of the best movies of
2018 and the most original thrillers in
recent memory
joaquin phoenix and john c reilly star
as sibling gunslingers charlie and eli
sisters and director jacques adyard's
witty and emotionally weighty western
the sisters brothers
adapted from patrick dewitt's novel of
the same name the 1851 set film follows
the rebellious liquor-loving charlie and
the contemplative eli as they travel
through the northwest united states on
the hunt for chemist herman warm
hermann has created a formula for
prospecting gold which makes him a
target for the sister's boss and a
detective played by jake gyllenhaal
unpredictable and atmospheric with a
story made all the more enjoyable by
phoenix and riley's brilliant
performances
the sisters brothers is a western that
you should see as soon as possible